d
y más del 30 por ciento
[Música]
para presentar el poder viniendo
transformando los sociatas
siempre
añadió
y que veía cuando a una persona se le
presenta un problema
pasaba que muchas de las personas
empezaban a jugar la otra versión
qué pasa
sí
y que la solución a estas
por eso
en montevideo
me ha llevado a los dos
tarde
[Música]
en eeuu
d
[Música]
las
y esa estación
[Música]
flor
bien
siendo los pervertidos de experiencia
[Música]
la clara
de hecho de trabajar en equipo
de desarrollo general
y ramón
el mundo
no podemos parar la cuerda de pequeñas
acciones que hacen
podemos llegar
efe
qué esperas
mucho son las sanciones a través del
proyecto
entonces
y la voluntaria
ya
otra vez
en este dilema
y
muchos de
los compañeros ya han terminado la
universidad y universidades
bien
y me encantará
esta universidad
grados
[Música]
no me
ah
no sé cuántas inicial
en concesiones
en esta problemática
y tenía en estas tramas personales
enlazar la solución
y una vez
pero nosotros además del entrenamiento
tiene
quién es el reposo
[Música]
para todos
bueno por lo tanto tenemos que
y no tiene
no muchas veces
y la presente
quise darle un toque más allá del
emprendimiento
ya
d
lo que
[Música]
llega
lo que es
y
al desarrollo en el país
[Música]
entonces ella
con una forma de ser
a jóvenes que tengan esa percepción de
constitución a la sociedad y también
y no solamente
tengas
entonces realmente que toda mi vida
[Música]
y todo bien
está ahí
y lo mejor del entendimiento que
nosotros pagamos no tiene 33 grados
d
en él
y empresariales
y pensar
efe
entonces a través de esas competencias
emprendedoras
las actividades
desarrollamos sorprenderás y
desarrollamos de qué manera
si una persona sale adelante todos vamos
a salir adelante
y yo menos a los ojos de dios es apoyar
a la santidad
y no me casaría
es más como una persona
y desde trayectoria al frente de toda la
organización ya tiene cinco años
y una de ellas
y en principio también
que no vamos a hacer
nos hemos dado
y en el plazo de distracción
la pasión de sentir que ahora está
realizando
contiene
porque conoces a un emprendimiento
comienza desde el primer mes
[Música]
mi vida
de trabajar
llegué
segundo no pedimos
es temible
y estos motivos de mí
muy bien
la problemática y hasta en los minutos
cómo trabajar con profesionales
y desde ahí
una vez
nosotros la vas
qué
y entonces
[Música]
puede sonar
e
[Música]
porque está bien
quiere
[Risas]
que vaya creciendo descarada
y llegó tras enseñar tanto más trabajo
e
de solución y nada más
[Música]
i
muchas gracias
de los mismos
y en ese entorno
[Música]
nos encontrábamos con el equipo
mis padres
estás bien
ese lugar
esto es para entonces
los 6
miguelín
y entre otros
y ahí
está
estas 5
estaba
cuál es
[Música]
sentimientos
la felicidad es grande
el agua siempre social
ah
y estaba las personalidades tentaciones
como persona
vamos a ustedes
y en esto
me gusta siempre
[Música]
es
a mayores
retirarla
y por qué
adelante
y enfrente
[Música]
cuando claramente estudiemos mensajes
emprendimientos con nuestra presencia
teniendo un presidente exitoso en cada
calle
y entonces
no solamente
y lo desee
del día cifras informadas
bueno más bien
la gente
llegué allí
y lo puede hacer
y en cada sesión
los días
así
salir
porque importante
de nosotros
amigos
hoy
y eso qué
y
después tenemos poder representarles
la cara
[Música]
no sé dónde
o
y la estabilidad
no quiero cantar
mejor de mí
[Música]
y la planta
tiene a personas que piensan como
ustedes
muchas veces las personas no saben
contar a estos círculos universitarios
es decir lo de
de la familia grande
[Música]
donde abejas están compartiendo en el
momento de cambio de frente y con las
personas que se corten
tienen que ayudarles
y también vamos a hacer mucho más
porque el emprendimiento es acción
entonces para también tener
muchas personas
y me comentaba cómo estaba
tenemos que mantenernos
al día
y también
e
así mismo
ustedes
y como le llaman a todas las acciones
las lecciones aprendidas
y no donde sea
y claramente
ahora tienen dos días y semanas
tiene sus manos
y yo
[Música]
yo los invito a que puedan
venga
[Música]
para nuestra sociedad positivamente
[Aplausos]